I could not live without my computer
absolutely
[Music]
like did you just answer with a song I
am
David's fellow coworker and payroll
she's trying to say that she's also an
accountant advice we're technically a
payroll we became the unlikeliest of
friends I use my computer for work
listening to music photos email running
a million different programs at once
they say everyone has their skeletons
but I really don't trying to think you
would this is my new baby fancy yeah
it's brand new kind of nervous of how
they'll make fun of what's in it that's
not who I am whatever is about to happen
if it gets weird
it's already gotten a little weird good
luck here we go thinner and no it's just
cooler what woods faster in the mine
let's just go into some stuff here
guitar piano and ukulele diagrams so
unless these are actually disguised as
Noddy photos no I don't know what he
listens to you didn't yet see that oh he
likes his team boat she has a cute
motorcycle helmet here
I found a moustached harp playing photo
I could see a be wearing this motorcycle
helmet around just for general safety on
his a dating profile it's totes David he
is not unlike watching wolves mate under
a Harvest Moon girl should go for this
right this is great yeah I like yours
better when are you gonna bring back the
mustache I don't know do you think I
should bring it back it takes bravery to
grow a stache like that you know it's
not just a casual thing you do yeah were
you into it that in the heart we do have
a musical thing income are you a
musician it wannabe I'm just so
inconsistent surprised by the female pop
centric I mean I'm a sucky life and pop
have you met Cortana
another one of your online
take funny check this out hey Cortana
play music queuing up your music you had
like a pink helmet you don't think I
actually drive motorcycles you have a
motorcycle license dear I think this
experience has made our friendship
stronger we learned about our inner
badass I mean I've got the stash
motorcycles
alright work tomorrow drum harp stash
motorcycle and a few spreadsheets